schaffst du sagen herzlich willkommen zu
zdf heute live an einem spannenden tag
wenn wir in die usa gucken wo es nach
einer spannenden wahl nacht einen
spannenden wahltag gab zumindest aus
unserer perspektive in den usa war
zwischendurch einmal nachts aber auch
für viele beobachter halt nur eine kurze
denn die beiden kontrahenten joe biden
und donald trump liefern sich was die
wahl zum us präsidenten angeht wirklich
ein hartes kopf an kopf rennen jede
stimme zählt aber und das ist es eben
auch das problem dabei donald trump
möchte nichts das unbedingt jede stimme
erzählt er hat dort versucht oder hat
angekündigt die ist das auszählen von
stimmen stoppen zu lassen was dahinter
steckt wie das ganze funktioniert wollen
wir heute versuchen zu besprechen wir
werden reden gleich mit meiner kollegin
alissa jung die in washington wieder
unterwegs ist für uns wie im grunde den
letzten 24 stunden auch schon am stück
außerdem sprechen wir mit professor karl
junker uni köln rechtswissenschaften und
ein fachmann für us recht und wir
sprechen mit thomas seine brockhaus vom
german marshall fund fragen kommentare
zu diesem doch recht schwierigen thema
bitte gerne stellen keine frage ist uns
hier zu rudimentär oder zu
niedrigschwellig wir versuchen wirklich
zu erklären was die letzten stunden
passiert ist und was dahinter steckt
entweder in den kommentarspalten oder
hier einmal per mail an zdf heute - live
at zdf.de wie immer werde ich versuchen
alles mit rein zu nehmen und wie immer
die bitte an euch und an sie doch
möglichst sachlich zu diskutieren sich
nicht zu beleidigen auch wenn es ein
thema ist was man wieder die gemüter
spaltet so das ist genau mein stichwort
für meine kollegin alissa jung die in
einem doch recht gespaltenen land gerade
unterwegs ist all dies hat übels in
washington steht die leitung kannst du
mich hören
wundervoller nicht genau ich stehe hier
mitten in washington vor dem weißen haus
das könnt ihr hinter mir sehen ganz weit
hinter dir
es sieht sehr entspannt aus bei dir im
hintergrund gerade wie ist die stimmung
heute morgen in washington
die stimmung auf der straße du sagst es
ganz richtig es sind nicht viele
menschen hier draußen also der großteil
hier sind tatsächlich journalistin und
die stimmung ist also hier auf der
straße jetzt noch so ruhig und ruhig und
gelassen aber ich glaube ehrlicherweise
auch dass die meisten wie so viele
menschen auf dieser welt gerade vor
ihren bildschirmen auch noch sitzen und
wirklich gebannt auf das ergebnis
schauen denn es sind ja noch nicht alle
stimmen ausgezählt und darum wird er
wahrscheinlich heute in unserem gespräch
auf 4 gehen das ist ja hier ein ganz
ganz wichtiger punkt
es wurden ja demonstrationen angekündigt
von verschiedenen gruppierungen ist das
alles ausgefallen gab es jetzt gar
nichts oder wird er gar nichts mehr
kommen
es sind wohl am nachmittag also
verschiedene proteste geplant aber
tatsächlich ist es so dass viele jetzt
erstmal abwarten also was passiert und
jetzt im prinzip im moment gibt es ja
auch noch gar nichts wogegen man
protestieren kann ich glaube das wird
sich jetzt also in den nächsten tagen
oder stunden entwickeln weil im moment
ist ja wirklich noch alles offen beide
kandidaten können präsident werden es
ist noch nicht entschieden sondern jay
jump der jetzt noch präsident ist er hat
sich heute morgen geäußert während
unseres livestreams heute morgen gegen 8
uhr gab es dann eine pressekonferenz und
dort hat er einige sätze gesagt die für
sehr viel aufregung gesorgt haben wieder
mal muss man sagen hier hört mal rein
die wettbetrug an der nation begangen
wir wollen dass das gesetz korrekt
angewendet wird also ziehen wir vor das
oberste gericht wir wollen dass die
stimmabgabe aufhört also quasi der
versuch jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass nicht
mehr weiter ausgezählt wird
er war ein bisschen kryptisch in seiner
erklärung kannst du noch mal versuchen
zu erklären was er damit eigentlich
gemeint haben könnte
er möchte tatsächlich also präsident
trump möchte tatsächlich nicht dass noch
weitere stimmen ausgezählt werden
er hat nachdem er diese pressekonferenz
gehalten hat auch schon verschiedene
tweets abgesetzt und die gehen
eigentlich alle in eine richtung er
möchte dass ab sofort oder nicht nur ab
sofort schon auch vorher also dass keine
der stimmen mehr zählen die nach dem
dritten also nach dem wahltag
eingegangen sind und der grund dafür ist
dass es einfach so ist dass viele von
den briefwahlstimmen vermutlich in
richtung demokraten in richtung joe
biden gehen viele von den
briefwählerinnen tendieren eher richtung
beiden und das würde dann im zweifel ja
ein ergebnis noch verändern oder
beispielsweise auch einen tweet
abgeschickt über den wir auch vielleicht
mal kurz gerne reden sollten weil einige
seiner tricks wurden auch wieder von
twitter markiert also als eben tweets
die umstritten sind oder möglicherweise
irreführend in bezug auf die wahl und
beispielsweise beispielsweise bei
eintritt von ihm dass er gesagt hat naja
letzte nacht lag an den schlüssel
staaten noch vor vorne und dann wurden
jetzt nach und nach hier überraschende
berlitz also brief briefbögen ein stück
natürlich entschuldigung das ist das
richtige wort stimmzettel ausgezählt und
jetzt würde das auf einmal sicher ändern
und das sei ja sehr sehr merkwürdig und
jetzt muss man ja mal dazu sagen also
wenn jeder eine stimme hat und jeder der
eine stimme abgegeben hat sollte ja auch
jede stimme zählen warum also nicht
warten bis alle stimmen ausgezählt sind
die zeit sollte man sich doch natürlich
nehmen wenn jede stimme zählen sollte
also regie fragt hier gerade auf youtube
eine recht nahe liegende frage warum
erklärt sich champions eigentlich schon
zum siegen müsste doch wissen dass joe
biden noch gewinnen kann was steckt
dahinter was meinst du
das ist wahrscheinlich natürlich die die
sorge und die befürchtung dass er also
nicht der sieger ist am ende hinter
gitter
richtig so so einfach wie es klingt aber
es gibt ja es gibt ja gar keine logische
erklärung dafür
ich habe das gerade angesprochen warum
also nicht warten und eben alle stimmen
auszählen lassen aber ich das hängt
damit zusammen dass er wirklich im laufe
der der ganzen wahlkampagne hier auch
immer wieder schon die rampe dafür
gebaut hat und gesagt hat also die
briefwahl die sehr anfällig für betrug
aber hier ganz klar also es gibt da
wirklich keine keine belege und beweise
dafür und man sollte doch eigentlich
warten in einer demokratie natürlich und
nicht nur eigentlich bis alle stimmen
ausgezählt sind so ich schaue was es
noch an fragen gibt die du vielleicht
beantworten kannst weil es ist eine
lange nach zürich gewesen und es ist
natürlich auch schwer alles zu verfolgen
was die letzten zeit passiert ist kannst
du uns vielleicht mal erklären
oder hast du es beobachten können wieso
die öffentlichkeit jetzt auf diese
auseinandersetzung reagiert
[Musik]
also da sind natürlich jetzt die stimmen
eigentlich von den am meisten leuten und
da wiederhole ich mich jetzt wieder aber
dass man doch bitte warten soll bisher
alle stimmen ausgezählt sind also das
kommt eigentlich von von allen seiten
das jetzt wirklich dazu geduld also die
medien das ist eigentlich das den den
satz den man hier am meisten im moment
hört von den medien die natürlich auch
dauerhaft berichten hier im land die
sagen bitte habt doch geduld bis
eigentlich alle zahlen da bin und es
geht hier nicht um betrug so hieß es bei
cnn sondern es geht einfach um mathe
also es müssen stimmzettel ausgehöhlt
ausgezählt werden und dann hat man am
ende doch auch ein ganz klares ergebnis
aber das ist jetzt die frage wie wird
das jetzt in den nächsten stunden tagen
tatsächlich weiter vorgehen
beispielsweise das trump team das
kampagne team hat jetzt auch schon
angekündigt es möchte nicht mit michigan
mir ein bundesstaat sofort das auszählen
der stimmen stoppen lassen und außerdem
auch noch mal nachzählen lassen
darüber sprechen wir gleich mit
professor gerd junker von der uni köln
der kann das alles noch mal genau aus
der rechtswissenschaftlichen perspektive
erläutern
ich habe ein paar kommentare
meinungsäußerung von euch aus dem stream
ich sag mal eher die negativen gegenüber
schauen zum beispiel so aus dass die
dodo auf youtube schreibt jump ist ein
genauso hoch zehn
mit dem würde ich mich nie auf etwas
einlassen dennoch ist er mir irgendwie
sympathisch er ist offen und angreifbar
anders betrachtet auf seine ungefilterte
prollige art wirkte auf mich ehrlicher
als andere die gesichter haben als
würden sie schon mal ihre grad mass
geblieben ist das tatsächlich auch so
eine einstellung alisa die manche
amerikaner teilen dieses versagen er ist
irgendwie unsympathisch durch das wie
ihr auftritt aber irgendwie auch sein
hartes dadurch dass er so straight ist
und einfach kein blatt vor den mund
nimmt und quasi das wort an stahl
anstand aus seinem wortschatz gestrichen
hat
das hört man hier tatsächlich von vielen
menschen also es gibt natürlich auf der
einen seite die tram fans die finden ihn
toll so oder so und dann gibt es aber
genau wie du es gerade oder wie es
gerade in kommentaren hieß angesprochen
es gibt die leute die sagen ich finde
ihn vielleicht menschlich nicht
besonders toll und ich finde auch nicht
alles klasse was er sagt oder seine
ausdrucksweise
aber ich mag dass er dass da quasi das
herz auf der zunge hat dass er immer
sagt was er denkt und ganz gerade raus
ist und dann nimmt man im prinzip auch
ein bisschen diese holprige sprache oder
auch mal die eine oder andere
beleidigungen kaufen ich habe ja noch
eine frage an dich von toastbrot 30 6 96
kommt eigentlich immer auf diese user
namen gibt es schon aufmärsche von
bewaffneten gruppen in den usa gibt es
da schon berichte von
also bislang ist hier alles wirklich
tatsächlich ruhig gestern abend oder
gestern nacht als ich unterwegs war ich
tatsächlich die sogenannten crowd fonds
getroffen das ist ja hier eine eine
gruppe eine gruppierung in den usa die
auch immer wieder durch
gewaltbereitschaft aufgefallen sind und
die habe ich in einer bar getroffen da
waren sie tatsächlich am trinken und
waren friedlich also da war nichts davon
zu spüren wenngleich sie aber mir
erzählt hermann gespräch dass sie
durchaus nicht davor zurückschrecken
würden ihre zitat freiheit zu
verteidigen was auch immer das auch
heißt genauer wurde es nicht erklärt
aber gestern abend die ganze nachbarn
ist friedlich und ihr seht hinter mir
hier ist musik oder vielleicht hört
jetzt auch ein bisschen von der
atmosphäre hier ist musik hier sind
wenige menschen noch ist hier wirklich
alles sehr friedlich wir haben ja auch
noch gar kein ergebnis über das sich
jemand aufregen könnte meine ich jetzt
mal das ist ein gutes stichwort für uns
hier denn wir wollen wir jetzt schauen
wie es tatsächlich gerade aussieht ist
erstmal danke an all dieser für die
eindrücke aus washington heute morgen du
wirst die auch den rest des tages für
uns unterwegs sein und auch social media
berichten das heißt wenn ihr irgendwas
seht von unterwegs dann ist es alisa und
die macht das für uns vielen dank dafür
und bis zum nächsten mal aber ganz
wichtig ist jetzt tatsächlich mal stand
der dinge der sich die ganze zeit ändert
wir haben quasi jetzt den stand vor zwei
stunden zusammengefasst
deswegen kann es sein dass sich
mittlerweile schon was geändert hat oder
wäre der maz sich sogar was ändert oder
nächsten halben stunde das ist alles
sehr spannend aber nina niebergall hat
ihr bestes gegeben und das
zusammengefasst was wir zu dem zeitpunkt
wussten bitteschön auch am tag danach
zählen sie noch stunde um stunde stimme
für stimme
vor allem in den staaten in denen donald
trump und joe biden kopf an kopf liegen
beide können die wahl noch gewinnen
beiden würde gewinnen denn er in den
staaten nevada arizona und michigan die
mehrheit erringt überall dort führt er
im moment wisconsin konnte er bereits
für sich entscheiden
zwei faktoren könnten beiden helfen
seinen vorsprung auch in den anderen
staaten zu halten
in städtischen gegenden sind viele
stimmen noch nicht ausgezählt auch
briefwahl stimmen fehlen vielerorts noch
beides tendenziell demokratischen
stimmen
trump würde gewinnen wenn er in den
staaten die meisten stimmen holt in
denen er im moment vorne liegt georgia
north carolina pennsylvania
außerdem müsste er michigan für sich
entscheiden oder einen anderen staat in
dem beiden vorne liegt teilweise mit nur
hauchdünnem vorsprung
wenn trump aber knapp verliert in einem
oder mehreren bundesstaaten kann er eine
neuauszählung beantragen das gilt auch
für beiden republikaner und demokraten
haben schon vor der wahl ihre anwälte in
stellung gebracht
dann könnte es noch tage oder gar wochen
dauern bis ein sieger feststeht
also eine sehr spannende angelegenheit
die sich eventuell wie gesagt noch ein
paar wochen hinziehen könnte wir hoffen
natürlich im interesse von allen dass es
schneller geht aber wir wissen es nicht
jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich gerichte ins
spiel beziehungsweise sind schon in
stellung gebracht worden und deswegen
wird es zeit für uns zu sprechen mit
professor kranker er hat den lehrstuhl
für us amerikanisches recht an der uni
köln bekennt sich also sehr gut aus und
wird uns jetzt hoffentlich in die
feinheiten des amerikanischen
justizsystems einweisen oder ein wein
hallo professor juncker ich hoffe auch
dass für die einladung also wir haben
hier ganz viele fragen schon von unseren
zuschauern ich frag mal erst mal meine
frage die bei uns in der redaktion auch
viel diskutiert wurde was könnte trump
eigentlich gemeint haben als er sagte er
möchte vor den supreme court ziehen
geht das überhaupt ok
also dass er schon mit den supreme court
angefangen hat zeigt mir dass er
wirklich seine eigene existenz nicht
wirklich versteht also der supreme court
nur kriegs barkeit für revisionen für
berufungen nichts werde erstinstanz es
gibt eine ausnahme dafür nicht oft
benutzt er darf dann ein antragen ein
sogenanntes emergency stay beantragen
gegen ein bundesland wenn er meinte dass
ein bundesland irgendwie falsch gezählt
hat aber wie sie schon ihre kollegen in
washington gefragt hat was sind die
tatsache oder was sind die die fakten
die er zeigen kann
die falsch gemacht sind oder hat keine
deswegen klingt alles sehr kritisch aus
weil nach meiner meinung hat er wirklich
nichts konkretes aber es gibt auch den
fall in pennsylvania das ist ja ein sehr
wichtiges land umsatz gerade gerungen
wird mit relativ vielen wahlmännern wenn
ich mich richtig erinnere waren es 22
125 bitte nicht darauf festnageln aber
ungefähr in der größenordnung also schon
ein gewicht bei dieser abstimmung und
dort hat das zuständige gericht
geurteilt dass die briefwahl noch bis
zum 3
11 also bis gestern möglich ist wenn ein
stempel drauf ist das ganze ist nicht
parlamentarisch abgesegnet worden dann
wurde versucht dagegen zu klagen
der supreme court hat es abgewiesen wenn
ich richtig informiert bin profession
kann liegt das ist gut und jetzt hat
sich aber die zusammensetzung des
supreme courts geändert es gibt eine
neue bundesrichterin kann es sein dass
er das gemeint hat dass er noch mal
versuchen will gegen diese briefwahl in
pennsylvania die verlängert wurde quasi
die möglichkeit vorzugehen weil das beim
ersten mal nicht geschafft hat
eigentlich nicht also darf er einen
versuch machen aber genau wie sie das
beschrieben haben genau diesen gericht -
von kunibert hat schon entschieden das
geht nicht nur für zwei wochen
das heute die die gäste und er hat schon
mit anderen bundesländern
auch versucht solche klage vorzulegen
das kann er meinen aber er wird nicht
erfolgreich
ich glaube eigentlich was für jetzt
sehen hatte schon wochenlang gedroht
dass wenn er schwer wird und das hat
auch ihre kollegen in washington schon
betont wenn er verliert dann geht er zur
gerichte als obmann einfachen sagen
könnte ich bin ich zufrieden bitte
richtet machen etwas für mich
das geht nicht so man muss erstens eine
klage vor dem gericht bringen und in
einer klage muss man preis mittel haben
und muss man ein gesetz finden was
gebrochen ist und er hat weder noch wir
haben ja eine frage an uns die möchte
ich noch mal kurz einschieben potenter
fragt ich bin absolut kein jump and fan
vielleicht mal kurz auf meinen rechner
schalten liebe regie dann können wir den
kommentar auch lesen
ich bin absolut kein strampler ach ich
hab vergessen dass kabel eins selbst in
augenblicklich kurz nach ist ja wir
haben auch einen langen tag wir sind
alle schon lange wach so jetzt ist das
kabel drin jetzt müsst ihr die regie auf
meinen rechner schalten können
jetzt kommt er langsam er hat sich
kurzum geschaltet so da da ist der
kommentator blick ich muss mal kurz neu
sortieren so ich packe ihn hier hin da
ist mein bildschirm und jetzt habe ich
ja meinen die kommentatoren okay leute
gemerkt das ist ein langer tage werden
läuft bei uns
ich stelle die frage so wie sie uns
gestellt wurde uns wurde quasi
vorgeworfen oder gefragt warum immer so
einseitig berichtet wird in den
öffentlich rechtlichen sendern
ich glaube der eindruck entsteht dadurch
dass wir uns sehr viel mit donald trump
beschäftigen müssen weil er immer wieder
versucht die regeln zu seinen gunsten zu
verschieben oder auch tabus zu brechen
ist das eine beobachtung die sie teilen
professor juncker ja also wir haben
schon vier jahre lang die erlebnis
gehabt dass jeden tag hängen wir ihren
einsatz fahren mit normalerweise und da
müssen wir
am ende diesen satz aber mit trank ist
des kantons und das ist wie gesagt
vier jahre lang haben wir die erlebnisse
gehabt ja versucht er das und wenn man
wirklich dann an
dann dürfen seine psychologie denkt er
muss denken er muss angst haben dass er
doch verlieren wird wenn nicht so ein
problem der jetzt markt und zweitens ich
glaube wenn er verliert und nicht weiter
aus präsident ein ein schild vor ihm hat
dann werden wir dann ob der york zum
beispiel wegen seiner sein steuer
berichte technik gegen ihn der eigene
quellen nenne prozess führen wurden oder
hat auch angst dafür glaube ich es ist
also mit tom die wir nach vier jahren
gelernt haben die alle erste frage ist
wie es ein vorteil für damit schramm
person nicht und er führt aus was ihr
jetzt versucht um seine person nicht
stelle zu verbessern nicht für die mehr
kann ich würde auch immer hinzufügen
dass er das überhaupt oder hatte
überhaupt eine möglichkeit dazu das zu
tun was er gerade versucht also hier ist
noch mal die frage aufgekommen von
werner darauf auf youtube hat stammt
wirklich eine realistische chance die
auszählung gerichtlich zu stoppen
ich würde sagen professor juncker hat
sie mit eigentlich nicht beantwortet
oder wo ich auch nein beantworten und
für heute hat jemand mehr gefragt ob die
usa jetzt in eine gefährliche situation
ist und im zweifel ist ob sie wirklich
immer noch eine werkstatt und macht
diese vier jahren eine von den drei
zweige in der regierung wirtschaft und
die us amerikanische senat 22 könnte man
sagen
die rechtsstaatlichkeit ist wichtig im
zweifel aber ich habe immer noch
hoffnung dass die dritter die richter
sind recht ständig schauen wir mal an
tom hat schon drei verschwiegene
zufrieden kein richter ernannt und auch
bei diese entscheidungen ein souvenir
dass wir schon besprochen haben
zwei davon haben teilgenommen und aber
nicht die sogenannten richtige antwort
schon damals schon gegeben
also ich glaube wenn wir diese frage
stellen wurden den usa hin
in diese gefährliche situation ist dass
sie nicht länger weil nicht mehr ein
rechtsstaat sind dann müssen wir unsere
hoffnung auf den richtern nicht nur das
trinken alle richter legen weil dieser
salat und diese präsident sind ein
rechtsstaatlicher institutionen das
heißt sie haben noch hoffnung dass die
richter tatsächlich unabhängig sind
donald trump hat ja sehr viele richter
neu ernannt ich glaube es waren über 100
an den gerichten und land und dem
supreme court eben jetzt eine neue
richterin auf lebenszeit hier gibt es
die fragen von sina auf youtube zum
beispiel wie unabhängig ist der supreme
court und wirklich oder auch von nico
langen auch auf youtube er hat auch vor
dem supreme court die mehrheit einen
republikanischen georgias kann das zum
problem werden wenn beiden trotzdem über
270 weil immer mehr stimmen bekommt ich
hoffe ich glaube nicht die in der
verfassung hat er ein präsident markt
und ein neue richtung oder richterin zu
ernennen und hatte schon dreimal gemacht
und dann geht es zu den senat und das zu
bestätigen und die senat alle drei
bestätigt mit emmi kunibert hatten diese
sind schon vorher gesagt
auch ihre in ihrem buch prozess etwas
voraus gegangen ist wir sie in die knie
raritan bestätigen das ist wirklich rein
politisch
das ist nicht juristisch aber nachdenken
nach die ernennung nach dieser internen
und nach die bestätigung dann hat ein
salat oder einfach überhaupt kein markt
oder ein richter richterin und dann sind
sie wie sie sagen könnt jetzt sie sind
lebens wagen dann gestellt und haben
deswegen sind sie lebenslang gestellt
sie brauchen dich an ihrem letzten job
zu senken und sie brauchen legt und
politik zu denken
tomtom hat überhaupt keine juristische
markt über den supreme court oder die
andere hunde unterrichten in den circuit
kurz also zweiter instanz wurde diskurs
herrschte instanz es gibt ja eine frage
auf youtube vielleicht können wir jetzt
mal kurz drauf schalten ich habe
mittlerweile meinen rechner auch
sortiert und alles hinbekommen das
müsste funktionieren
hier schreibt marc erst wie wäre es wenn
ihr mal über den massiven wahlbetrug
berichten würde lieber markt bislang
liegen uns keine verlässlichen berichte
über wahlbetrug vor das ist ein narrativ
also eine story die donald trump die
ganze zeit versucht so quasi ein zu
füttern oder ist ein mit einem beleg zu
versehen also er hat von einem wort
gesprochen also von einem betrug heute
morgen aber wir haben keinen beleg
gesehen die konsequenz daraus ist
tatsächlich das jetzt geklagt wird und
zwar will das wahlkampfteam von donald
trump in wisconsin neu auszählen lassen
und zwar die stimmauszählung erst mal
gerichtlich stoppen und dann soll mit
dieser klage erreicht werden dass die
cdu so lange ausgesetzt wird bis es
einen nennenswerten zugang gebe man
hätte zwischendurch keinen nennenswerten
zugang gehabt so hat das team soeben
mitgeteilt
was heißt das ganz genau professor
juncker sie sind ja professor für
amerikanisches recht erklären uns dass
sie in deutschland was steckt dahinter
noch stellt hinsche was also das
wahlkampfteam von donald trump will die
stimmauszählung in michigan shoppen mit
dem verweis sie hätten keinen
nennenswerten zugang gehabt während der
stimmauszählung bisher ja die haben die
republikaner haben schon in 2020 90 oder
mehr aus
in china klage gegen verschiedene
organisationen staatliche organisationen
gebracht einige sind erfolgreich war ab
und zu macht eine behörde einen fehler
aber insgesamt wir haben sehr wenige von
diesel diese aussage von betrug
die sie das beschrieben haben dass das
ist ohne substanz das ist politisch und
mit der tram sehen wir das was
akzeptiert aus politisch war also man
könnte bis zu einer grenze gehen und die
wahrheit vielleicht ein bisschen anderes
äußern
er sagt einfach der die die nicht die
wahrheit sind aber auch die rechtlichen
officer rechtsgrundlage kennen die jetzt
versuchen die auszählung zu stoppen
in dem bundesstaat gibt es dann nach
rechts und frage die ihn bekannt ist ja
und dass das ist aber auch nicht nur bei
chance das ist bei jedem kampf so
gemacht denn wenn etwas falsch gezählt
ist leute verlieren die die stimmzettel
die sind nicht geöffnet es gibt entweder
betrug in ein wahllokal oder es gibt
leute die versuchen anderer leute zu
bedrohen in ein wahllokal dann kann man
entweder unter ein gesetz oder unsere
verfassung 1 1 ein wahlmann ein banker
vor dem gericht bringen
aber solche konkrete details haben will
ich zurzeit gehört also ich fast noch
mal zusammen für alle die sich gerade
erst eingeschaltet haben wir haben schon
gesprochen einmal kollegin alicia jungen
in washington die uns gezeigt hat dass
dort in den usa gerade die stimmung war
angespannt ist aber noch relativ
entspannt weil wir einfach nicht wissen
wer der nächste us präsident werden will
die beiden liefern sich ein hartes kopf
an kopf rennen es geht insgesamt um
sechs bundesstaaten wo es wirklich ja
spitz auf knopf steht um so eine
schlimme rede werden einmal zu benutzen
und wo wir einfach abwarten müssen die
ist in den nächsten tagen und wochen
vielleicht sogar weitergeht ich habe
gerade gesprochen oder sprecher gerade
noch mit professor junker von der uni
köln
experte für us amerikanisches recht ich
gucke manchmal ob es fragen aus der
zuschauerschaft an sie gibt das glaube
ich erst mal jetzt nicht konkret ich hab
mir noch eine frage weil ich habe jetzt
gehört in der berichterstattung dass es
die möglichkeit gibt in pennsylvania das
ist ja ein sehr wichtiges bundesland für
die entscheidung der wahl dass dort das
parlament entscheiden kann
die wahlmänner sind vielleicht jetzt
eigentlich alle für beiden aber wir
schlagen sie jetzt trump zu ist das
tatsächlich möglich
es ist möglich es gibt 33 länder so
stades die gezwungen sind dann für die
bürger zu wählen die waren männer
es gibt aber dann inzwischen gibt es
drei oder vier die dann eine mischung
haben mit baskets at b
und dann gibt es am 11 länder states die
nicht verbunden sind mit den burgen rat
also die wahlmänner dürfen wie sie
wollen dann wählen aber auch und diese
330 dann die verbunden sind wenn sie
gegen ihre beschränkungen dann ihr wahr
machen wurden die chance dafür ist sehr
wenig aber es gibt manchmal gar keine
hunde dort oder wenig oder nichts also
das kann dort sein das ist genau richtig
okay das klingt für unsere ohren sehr
sehr merkwürdig gesinnter andere systeme
gewöhnt aber wir haben auch als die
marken am apropos soll ich sagen ich bin
aus pennsylvania eine von die diese
stimmzettel die dort liegen ist meiner
ich frage jetzt nicht was sie gewählt
haben das ist das wahlgeheimnis okay ich
schaue noch mal ob es fragen an sie gibt
es die sie beantworten können aus der
rechtswissenschaftlichen perspektive ich
glaube aber doch eine frage finde ich
noch ganz spannend die würde ich aber
auch gerne herrn kleinen rock auf noch
stellen aber ich stelle ich auch ihnen
gerne warum kann jemand wie donald trump
die amerikanische demokratie so leicht
gefährden und teilweise umgehen möchte
ohne zu werner auf youtube wissen
das ist eine sehr gute frage die
amerikaner haben ihre weg system von den
engländern übernommen so genannte common
word gewohnheitsrecht und systemen von
gewohnheitsrecht benutzen oft der
gewohnheit aus gesetze und länger aus
200 jahren hat das system mehr oder
weniger gut funktioniert ich kann ich
benutze er aus kleinen zelle
hier ist die verfassung das ist sehr
klar die hartz iv das ja besteht aus nur
sieben verschiedenartigen und 27 wenn es
dazu und man wurde sich dann die frage
stellen wird so wenig substanz wie kann
ein system funktionieren und die antwort
ist gewohnheit die zwei parteien haben
ein anderer respekt gegeben die drei
zweigen in der regierungssystem haben
ein anderer respekt gegeben und 200
jahre lang dann nicht länger eigentlich
ein bisschen menge hat es gut geklappt
dann kam 2000 mit burgen busch und dann
haben wir gesehen haben probleme damit
vielleicht gehabt und genau wie sie
jetzt gefragt haben mit den warmen und
diese wahl pro regierung in der
geschichte des oder usa waren nur fünf
mal ein war wohl durch diese wahl
kollegium nicht die gleiche sache
gemacht haben also die bevölkerung
zwei davon sind von 1789 bis 2000 die
man wirklich dann ausnahme und niemand
hat wirklich probleme damit gehabt aber
dann 2000 mit gott hatten wir eine band
bush hatten wir eine zweite haben jetzt
vielleicht zum dritten mal hier noch auf
20 jahren einmal in eine richtung
was die bevölkerung nicht gewählt haben
und ich würde sagen dann haben wir nach
kuhns zur gewohnheit wirklich probleme
also dieses mal kollegium ist wirklich
problematisch gibt es diesen
bestrebungen tatsächlich die auch
realistisch sind dieses system auf lange
sicht zu ändern
ja es gibt schon eine eine verbund von
von menden
stades die gegen dieses system sind und
sie versuchen dann nach ihrer gewinnt
also nach ihrem verbund dann zu sagen
auch wenn wir dann diese bau männer
benutzten wurden wir auch dann alle
unsere wahlmänner verbinden mit uns oder
bürger war auch wenn wir nicht unsere
verfassung ändern könnten oder werden
habe ich es freilich schon gemacht das
zeigt es gibt eine bewegung gegen den
sogenannten ghetto korn und diese
wahlmänner
jetzt gibt es da noch eine frage die
sich viele menschen habe ich immer
wieder stellen was passiert denn jetzt
tatsächlich wenn joe biden mit sehr
knapper mehrheit zum präsidenten gewählt
wird oder gewählt werden sollte im
dezember aufgrund der wahlmänner und
donald trump das ergebnis aber nicht
anerkennt und sagt ich bleibe hier ich
bin der präsident und das ist alles
betrug was ihr passiert gibt es dafür
irgendeinen emergency exit im
amerikanischen recht eigentlich nicht
weil wir zurzeit nie diesen vergab haben
schon gefragt ist
berlin der oberste militär general john
keys start in den usa
und er hat den bundeskongress
geschrieben also schriftlich geschrieben
dass wenn so etwas passiert wurde sind
wir nicht dabei das ist eine frage in
einem rack system für die gerichte und
für die bundeskongress zu antworten und
für brauchen die sozialistisch dann uns
für platz 1 zu stellen auch wenn ein
präsident anrufen wurde sind wir nicht
dabei also noch mal würde ich sagen
dann ist vielleicht doppelt rang von
seiner beraten obwohl er akzeptiert sehr
wenig dass das wir seien brände
beleidigen und deswegen wäre er
wahrscheinlich gehen nicht weil er meint
ich
nicht wie sie sagen der mann immer noch
aber sondern nach dem was kann ich
besser tun
wie kann das personal werde ich jetzt
mit streitigkeit gehen muss oder wenn
ich freiwillig sagen okay ich mach was
anderes hier ist professor carlo janka
vielen dank für ihre erklärungen des
amerikanischen rechtssystems mit seinen
besonderheiten und seinen ausnahmen das
nicht ganz so einfach zu verstehen ist
aber welches rechtssystem ist das schon
vielen dank für ihre zeit heute abend
und für die beantwortung werden kann wir
stehen die auch nicht dass das ist
zumindest beruhigend gut dann möchten
wir weiter schalten zum nächsten
gesprächsgast der schon ein bisschen
gewartet hat weil wir mussten einfach
viel erklären und zwar freue ich mich
jetzt dass bei uns zu gast ist thomas
kleine brockhoff vizepräsident des
german marshall funds of the states ich
grüße sie guten abend herr bock auf
sie haben gerade wahrscheinlich zugehört
die ausführungen der erklärungen
das ist schon ein ja quasi fast ein
system wo man sagen kann da ist das
chaos so ein bisschen einprogrammiert
aber haben sie das tatsächlich erwartet
dass wir so ein chaos tagen würden
wonach es gerade aussieht das ist ja
egal was mit ansage und das hat ja auch
schafft darauf abgezielt er hat jetzt
drei wochen und fast monaten dieses
szenario an die wand gemalt und auch
seine eigene reaktion darauf uns schon
schon mitgeteilt
es ist einfach ein altes systems eine
alte demokratie die dieses wahlmänner
gremium jahr als eine art gebildeten
stand dazwischengeschaltet zwischen
geräten erfolg und das ist die folge
davon und nicht alle
das haben wir eben von professor juncker
gehört haben sind mit einem imperativen
mandat ausgestattet und eigentlich kann
man nach den gestrigen tag ja auch ganz
froh sein dass es nicht so etwas gibt
wie ein bundeswahlleiter also irgendeine
bundesbehörde eine einzelne person die
von donald trump unter druck gesetzt
werden könnte sondern dass es der a50
gibt dass die beeinflussung
möglichkeiten
einfach sehr gering ist man könnte die
in den heutigen und gestrigen tag ja
auch mal anders versuchen zu definieren
und so sagen dass angesichts dieser
hohen wahlbeteiligung unter den
rahmenbedingungen einer pandemie auch
ein fest der demokratie stattgefunden
hat das friedlich und entschlossen schon
einer vielzahl von menschen mit ihren
stimmzettel gefeiert wurden das stimmt
dass es auch tatsächlich mal eine
betrachtungsweise die wir in den medien
nicht so oft haben vor allem weil wir
uns ja immer so auf dieses hin und her
fokussieren trotzdem bleibt die frage
donald trump spielt gerne direkt mit
diesem ja auch chaos oder mit dieser
unsicherheit für wie ernst halten sie
seine drohung dass er versuchen wird für
den supreme court ziehen das auszählen
der stimmen zu verhindern oder ist das
in ihren augen vielleicht doch eher
wahlkampftaktik und rhetorik wir haben
in den letzten vier jahren gelernt der
wirtschaft ernst zu nehmen alles was er
sagt auch so manche ungeheuerlichkeit
meinte so wie er sich sagt jedenfalls
auch da man ist das so und deshalb muss
man ihn auch ernst nehmen wenn er uns
erklärt dass er das juristische system
das wahlsystem ausgeben möchte natürlich
verpackt in den versuch es vor dem
betrug der andere schützen zu wollen
denn das darf man nicht vergessen in der
selbst sicht von donald trump ist ja
nicht er derjenige der das system
aushebeln sondern umgekehrt es sind die
anderen die bei nacht und nebel aktiv
werden also er kaum geht er schlafen und
punkt einmal nicht hin sind schon wieder
irgendwelche demokratischen eliten nennt
dafür hält er die wahlkommission dabei
von irgendwoher stimmzetteln
herbeizuzaubern damit endlich das
gewünschte ergebnis kommt und donald
trump aus der macht beseitigt wird
es ist aber auch so aus meiner sicht
dass er natürlich samt eigener
schärfster gegner
insofern ist als dass er natürlich einen
großen wahlsieg er gerade dabei ist zu
verschenken ich will nicht sagen was ich
will endlich wissen wer gewonnen hat
es ist ja so dass er eigentlich neue
wählerschichten hinzugewonnen so uns mal
damit beschäftigen was eigentlich in der
vergangenen nacht geschehen ist
da sind wirklich ganz vielleicht noch
mal besprechen headliner bergauf ich
möchte kurz ankündigen dass sich gerade
aufs ohr gesagt bekommen habe dass joe
biden in wenigen minuten vor die presse
treten könnte hier auf meinem forscher
monitor ist schon eine pressekonferenz
bild aufgelegt dh es kann sein das ist
die gleiche satz unterbrechen muss herr
kleine brockhoff einfach nur dass sie
bescheid wissen dann wären wir zusammen
und joe biden anhören ich hoffe sie ja
noch ein bisschen zeit und dann
vielleicht noch mal darüber sprechen was
er gesagt hat weil das ist natürlich
sehr spannend nach den vorwürfen von
donald trump heute morgen wahlbetrug
betrug am amerikanischen volk er will
klagen und das ganze sei nicht
unrechtmässig er sei der gewinner der
wahl ist natürlich jetzt sehr spannend
was joe biden sagen wird eine frage die
mich die ganze zeit umtreibt zeit kleine
brockhoff ist haben die amerikaner das
niemals für möglich gehalten und kommen
sehen dass jemand versucht so mit ihrem
system aufzuspielen
ja ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
ich das jemals vorgestellt und in der
erfahrung der vergangenen vier jahre ist
es ja auch so dass viele gesagt haben
der mann wird gezähmt er wie zivilisiert
er wird ein gebacken werden in das
system
es gibt lauter erwachsenen um ihn herum
das war die das war die formulierung aus
der anfangszeit dieser vier jahre
das liegt alles hinter uns wir müssen
anfangen nicht nur donald trump ernst zu
nehmen sondern auch die soziale bewegung
die ich hinter ihm steht und die mit dem
gestrigen tag größer und nicht kleiner
geworden ist was sie haben das gerade
schon angesprochen donald trump hat neue
wählerschichten erschlossen das sind vor
allem auch latinos in florida die ihn
gewählt haben
obwohl sich donald trump ja durchaus
auch despektierlich über latinos
geäußert hat in den letzten jahren immer
wieder auch sehr heftig was meinen sie
denn was ist das für eine soziale
bewegung und auch was für neue
wählerschichten die sich jetzt
entschlossen haben diesen mann zu wählen
der steckplatz motivation dahinter
der hat im ersten wahlkampf vor vier
jahren den begriff des vergessenen
menschen der vorgaben mehr der auch aus
der amerikanischen geschichte die seine
vorbilder kent wieder ausgegraben und
für den er der vertreter sein möchte wir
haben gestern erlebt dass es noch mehr
davon gibt von leuten die hochmotiviert
sind für dolmetscher an die wahlurne zu
gehen wo sich vermutlich vorher noch nie
waren
denn wir haben eine wahlbeteiligung wie
satt etwa 1876 nicht mehr gäste erlebt
das heißt also der motivation grad derer
die sich nicht vertreten fühlen die eine
repräsentation slip spüren und die in
trampe ihren sachwalter sehen lassen sie
darüber hinwegsehen dass er jede norm
jede demokratische praxis jedes
gewohnheitsrecht jede verfassungsnorm
nicht ganz so genau nehmen mag und die
washington post hat in 20.000 lügen in
den vier jahren nachgewiesen und
protokolliert und diese zahl wird in den
nächsten vier jahren würde er gewählt
werden auch nicht kleiner werden das
alles spielt keine rolle auf kuba denn
für ein bestimmtes bevölkerung segment
ist diese repräsentations lücke offenbar
so groß dass sie bereit ist über all das
hinweg zu gehen und das ist das was
wirklich besorgniserregend als an dieser
wahl und das muss sich im grunde auch
die politische elite des landes im
übrigen auch der journalismus auch
analysten wie ich selber vorhalten
wie habe ich dass das gerade wagen also
ich hab ich habe auch heute einen tweet
gelesen dagegen die richtung wenn die
demokraten gegen einen mann wie donald
trump nichts entgegensetzen zu haben
also keine besseren kandidaten kein
anderes wahlprogramm was die menschen
überzeugt dann haben sie im grunde
echten probleme und sollten sich
vielleicht am besten auflösen ist eine
sehr drastische zugespitzte formulierung
aber man kann es ja auch so rum sehen
warum schaffen die demokraten das nicht
mit einem ja die sind ja wahlprogramm
das vielleicht auch er genau diese
folgten people den vorgarten man die
vergessenen menschen abholt zu punkten
eigentlich waren die doch mal oder haben
sich selber so
genannt die partei auch der kleinen
leute der gewerkschaften die adressen
die die frage des kandidaten ist
natürlich wesentlich
hier wird sich wenn joe biden verlieren
sollte eine art richtungskampf innerhalb
der demokratischen parteien geben weil
wir dann sagen dann hätte man doch nicht
mehr zu einem moderaten mittel auf dem
road menschen antreten müssen sondern
der linke flügel wird dann rebellieren
und sagen mit einem der linken
kandidatin alexandra lukasz kubot es als
generationenwechsel oder nämlich senders
als großen alten mann der amerikanischen
linken hätte man antreten müssen und mit
einer art linken protektionismus genau
die arbeiter ansprechen sollen von denen
sie gerade gesprochen haben
und es ist ja auch wahr in solchen
städten wie youngstown in ohio die
eigentlich star ruinen mehr als stahl
städte sind das waren hochburgen der
demokraten noch barack obama hat diese
stadt mit großer mehrheit geholt als vor
wenigen jahren
nun hat charme noch mehr stimmung dort
gewonnen als vor vier jahren
das muss man immer mit bedenken
allerdings ist immer ist die wahrheit
natürlich auch bisschen komplexer in
südflorida sind leute zu
hunderttausenden an die wahlurne
gegangen nämlich kubanische amerikaner
um den angeblichen sozialismus
abzuwehren man kann sich also vorstellen
was los gewesen wäre in amerika wenn
nicht ein moderator sondern wirklich ein
linker angetreten wäre
aber dieses ist tatsächlich die frage
die sich die demokraten nun vorzulegen
haben werden sollte joe biden am ende
nicht über die ziellinie geraten dann
wird es eine art richtungskampf eine art
politischen bürgerkrieg innerhalb der
demokratischen partei gehen ich habe ein
paar kommentare aus der zuschauerschaft
die uns da wirklich immer sehr wichtig
sind dieser versuch mit einzunehmen auch
wortmeldungen einmal von jörg kennst du
nicht sehr schön der nachname sehr
kreativ ihr wisst schon das beiden auch
behauptet hat
sei auf der siegerstraße und das 30 bis
45 minuten vor jump for job statement
zum weiß ich das ist richtig das hat er
getan aber es ist doch eine ziemlicher
unterschied ob man sagt man ist auf dem
weg zur siegerstraße oder ob man sich
ohne ein offizielles ergebnis zu haben
selber zum sieger erklärt ich glaube das
ist schon eine sprachliche feinheit die
wir beachten sollten und dann habe ich
hier einen kommentar von nelly brennt
oder brannte am portal seine
wahlversprechen eingehalten
macht euch ein bisschen kundig und hört
auf zu hetzen gegen diesen mann er wird
gewinnen das ist so klar ist das
tatsächlich so kann man das ihm
attestieren donald trump er hat all
seine wahlversprechen gehalten
der mann trägt seine band wird für
ehrlich gehalten von seinen wählern für
eine ehrliche haut das mögen leute die
sich an den 20.000 lügen orientieren
nicht so sehen aber für seine wähler ist
er völlig gerade heraus man weiß immer
woran man ist
und es hat man einen klugen menschen
gegeben der an der anfang am anfang der
amtszeit von dort schon gesagt hat
die leute machen wie ein fehler ihn
wörtlich aber nicht ernst zu nehmen
dabei sollte man ihn ernst nehmen aber
nicht wörtlich und im grunde tun dass
seine wähler und das war verdammt viele
gestern haben wir mal auf diese
gespaltene stimmung im land gibt es ein
paar kommentare die gehen in die
richtung zum beispiel ein x pire trump
der tram tatsächlich ok auf youtube
beschreibt sondern x pire und der
schreibt trump ist der präsident in die
usa verdient sorry so rum also er ist
der präsident in die usa verdient ein
volk das nur noch schwarz und weiß trend
und das durch alle lebenslagen inklusive
parteien verdient genauso etwas und ließ
das schreibt auf facebook beiden
belästigt kinder das ist ein youtube
clip oder ein clip der auch noch mal
viel gegangen heute ist mit lauter
schnipseln uhr gezeigt wird wie joe
biden doch sehr grenzwertig sich verhält
gegenüber jungen menschen
jump ist rassist schreibt sie weiter
wieso diskreditieren sich die lager
gegenseitig können wir nicht normal
miteinander reden und andere meinungen
akzeptieren was ist da in den usa
da kann ich quasi an herrn kleine
brockhoff weitergeben schief gelaufen
dass sich diese lager so dermaßen
gegenseitig anhalts gehen
ich habe mein schritt teil meines lebens
bin ich immer über den atlantik hin und
her geflogen und hat viele jahre in den
usa zu gebracht eine der dinge die mich
beeindruckt haben war die ruhe und der
pragmatismus auch die unideologische
charakter des landes und da hat sich was
verändert und zwar hat nicht erst seit
der tramp sondern seit längerem die
eingegrabenen hyde der politischen
seiten die zuordnung die nicht mehr
erlaubt miteinander richtig zu reden da
gibt es dann an beiden leitungen wie man
in der familie zum erntedankfest
miteinander redet ohne sich politisch in
die haare zu kriegen
also es dieses land ist tief gespalten
und viele dinge die wir der phänomene
die wir sehen und nicht verstehen können
sind folge davon
einer der faszinierendsten erfahrung die
ich gemacht habe ist zu bemerken wie das
ganze konsumverhalten auf
parteizugehörigkeit zugeschnitten ist
dass es also shopping malls gibt die
mehr für republikaner sind und mehr die
solche geschäfte haben die demokraten
benutzen das heißt also kulturelles
verhalten konsumverhalten politisches
verhalten das geht alles in ein system
regiertes leben man lebt lieber mit seit
den leuten zusammen die so ähnlich
ticken wie man selber also dieses große
bunte land ist in einer ist in einer
pandemie ist sozusagen der des zwei
parteien systems umfangen um diese
polarisierung ist wirklich ungemein hoch
und die befriedung lange dauert hat das
auch was mit mit dem doch sehr
knallharten kapitalisten
kapitalistischen system den usa zu tun
wo es sachen nicht gibt wie
arbeitnehmerschutz wo man einfach
gefeiert werden kann wo es
keinen wirklich nennenswerten
mindestlohn gibt es der dazu führt dass
menschen teilweise zwei oder drei jobs
haben müssen wo es auch zum beispiel so
etwas gibt wie das problem mit den
universitäten dass man sehr viel geld
haben muss um studieren zu kann ist es
auch etwas was diese spaltung weiter
vorantreibt in dem land also jetzt
kommen käme dann wieder legen sie jetzt
ein testbild das wollen wir nicht
schade ich hätte es gerne gehört was für
olle kamellen nicht hier aufgelegt habe
da haben wir gerade die leitung zu herrn
kleine brockhoff verloren ich frag mal
in der regie nach was da los ist könnte
es mir sagen all i only ist gerade dran
wir bitten um geduld cleese ottl 1 ich
werde jetzt wirklich sehr gerne mit der
in seiner burg weiter sprechen um zu
hören was an meinen ollen kamellen dran
ist und was er da dazu entgegnet wir
haben außerdem gerade das bild zu der
pressekonferenz von joe biden wieder
verloren da wird also ein testbild
gezeigt auf dem kanal das heißt da
scheint sich doch nichts zu bewegen ich
kann jetzt einfach nur weiter in die
kommentare gucken einmal schauen was ihr
so jetzt zu der lage sagt während die
kollegen in der technik versuchen das
ganze wieder zu fixen ihr wisst ist das
kein kamerateam bei ein kleiner
brockhaus und eine macht das alles über
seinen rechner und da kann sowas einfach
mal passieren ich lese hier immer wieder
den vorwurf dass beiden ein
kriegstreiber werden wird das ist
tatsächlich eine these die immer wieder
kommt die aber eigentlich jetzt nicht zu
belegen ist
und es gibt dann immer wieder den das
statement das jump zumindest unter tram
kein krieg war das ist ein statement was
so nicht stimmt weil es gibt immer noch
us-truppen in afghanistan es gibt us
truppen gab es noch lange bei syrien es
gibt jede menge
militärstützpunkte auf der ganzen welt
wo die usa zu gange sind von daher kann
man jetzt nicht wirklich davon sprechen
dass unter jump ein frieden geherrscht
hat so ich schaue mal ob ich jetzt noch
fragen finde während die kollegen in der
technik weiter busl da muss ich euch
gerade einfach bitten jetzt ein bisschen
zu warten das passiert einfach jetzt das
studio ist noch neu gerade kommt ein
kollege hektischen versucht irgendwas zu
regeln aber ich glaube wir kriegen das
hier zusammen hin dass interessanter
kommentar von kurt mühle strumps gegen
die globalisierung und hat die größte
abrissbirne
was meinst du damit abrissbirne kurt das
tanzen war vielleicht in den kommentaren
ergänzen
oliver hertrich meint ob ich gerade bei
deutschland trete das trifft auf uns
genauso zu weil ich war was meinst du
ganz genau also meinst du auch die die
spaltung der gesellschaft vielleicht
meinst du das was ich gerade gesagt habe
und laut den auswertungen haben ja mehr
afroamerikaner demokraten gewählt als
weiße schreibt johann macht diese
auswertung die spaltungen noch klarer
das würde ich gerne auch nochmal
weiterreichen gleich an herrn kleine
brockhoff wenn wir die leitung zu ihm
wieder kriegen
oli in der regie was los wir sind dran
wir kriegen ihn aber auch gerade nicht
versuchen immer zu anzurufen oder stefan
versuchs mal anzurufen
ja wir versuchen mal anzurufen der
kollege nebenan versucht man das mit der
telefonleitung mit der guten alten ich
hoffe dass das funktioniert weil ich
wusste wirklich gerne was er mir jetzt
entgegnet so da war jetzt gerade genau
an dem punkt ist bislang gebrochen wo
ich mit meinen ollen kamellen kam ich
schauen wir hier auf youtube was da so
los ist militärstützpunkte auch in
deutschland müssen verschwinden meint
metrics red bull das ist ja auch eine
sache die die usa schon angekündigt
haben unter donald trump dass die
stützpunkte verlegen wollen zum beispiel
richtung polen
ich schaue mal weiter donald trump wird
immer als rassist abgestempelt wobei
beiden wirklich rassistisch ist er hat
mehrmals white supremacy die nahrungs-
und gesagt dass er sie nicht unterstützt
sagt chicken salad auf youtube das ist
so halb richtig aber er hat zum beispiel
wenn wir daran uns erinnern in der
debatte mit joe biden als das um die
braut boys ging also wirklich eine
rassistische white supremacy gruppe den
hat er gesagt standby entstand beck also
hat sie quasi direkt angesprochen
hinterher meinte er wisse überhaupt gar
nichts von denen das sind diese
rhetorischen tricks die bei ihm immer
wieder auffallen so wir können mal
gucken was unsere hochrechnungen
eigentlich ergeben wenn wir ich muss mal
kurz auf unsere seite wechseln wenn wir
mal auf die aktuellen zahlen gucken
wollen ich weiß nicht ob uli grad
nochmal hand frei hat um auf meinen
rechner zu schalten
das ist so ein bisschen die frage geht
das noch oder bist du doch olli ist auf
meinem rechner hervorragend also wir
sind gerade stand 21 uhr 22
präsidentschaftswahl wahlleute wir
brauchen 270 für den wahlsieg und wir
sind gerade bei 213 für trump und 227
für beiden dass das quasi der stand
jetzt und ich höre gerade kleine
brockhoff vom german marshall fund ist
wieder da auf der leitung hervorragend
die wirren der technik auch hier
angekommen plötzlich war das gerät aus
ja das passiert manchmal so jetzt haben
sie mir gerade gesagt ich habe mit ollen
kamellen gekommen quasi dem schlimmsten
vorurteilen gegenüber den usa vermutlich
die man haben kann dann sagen sie
nochmal wie sieht es denn wirklich aus
naja also die die der kleine at
kapitalistische exkurs der ihrer frage
unterliegt natürlich ist der
kapitalismus für alle übel dieser welt
zuständig vom klimawandel bis zum
faschismus nun auch für die
polarisierung in den uhr in den usa ich
glaube da muss man da und darf man gerne
ein bisschen
stärker differenzieren ich glaube das
ist hier eher mit dem zweiparteiensystem
und der politischen tradition des landes
zu tun hat aber es gibt auch durchaus
verschiedene spielarten des kapitalismus
wir haben hier in deutschland eher eine
soziale spielart die auch guckt dass das
quasi ein soziales netz gibt wo man
aufgefangen wird das ist in den usa doch
etwas leichter als bei uns keine frage
deswegen wird man dort einfach auch
besser angestellt als hier wo man hier
höhere hürden in den anstellung in die
anstellung ab also ist man kann jetzt
lange drüber sozusagen den system
vergleich zwischen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft und der freien
marktwirtschaft führen ich sehe nur
nicht den wirklichen zusammenhang zur
polarisierung über die wir sprachen das
war eigentlich mein eigentlicher punkt
ohne dass ich jetzt mal die die debatte
über die soziale marktwirtschaft
eröffnen wollte ja so weit wollen wir
heute abend nicht gehen aber sie sehen
den fehler oder das problem im system er
in diesem part zwei parteien system
darstellt ist ja auch die frage warum
hat es dann noch keine dritte oder
vierte partei aufs tableau geschafft bei
uns ist vor einigen jahren die afd
aufgetaucht relativ aus dem stand heraus
sitzt im bundestag als größte
oppositionspartei warum ist das in den
usa nicht möglich oder gerade undenkbar
da würde ich die die die implikation
ihrer frage in frage stellen
also ich sehe überhaupt kein problem
darin dass das ein zweiparteiensystem
ist das sind unterschiedliche spielarten
von demokratie mit unterschiedlichen
vorzügen die das zwei-parteien-system
hat natürlich eine unheimliche
integrations kraft nach innen
wir haben das gerade in der letzten bahn
8 gesehen welche unterschiedlichen
demografischen politischen gruppen so
eine volkspartei nach innen hin
integrieren muss diese integrations
kraft und damit auch die
verantwortlichkeit die damit kommt in
einer dann regierungspartei zu sein
die muss man gar nicht haben wenn man
hier die afg oder die linke oder auch
die fdp ist hier kann also sicher jemand
ein sozusagen ein klientel eine
klientelpartei ohne verantwortungs
notwendigkeit
also das hat auch nachteile was wir hier
mit uns
multi parteiensystem haben also das
würde ich nicht würde ich nicht
unterschreiben
so wie sie dass gerade ich habe sie so
verstanden dass sie die spaltung der
gesellschaft vor fast zwei parteien
system zurückführen
ja die die spaltung der gesellschaft
zwei parteien system trägt natürlich und
das ist einer seiner nachteile dazu bei
die die zwei lager zu produzieren und
insofern ist das schon richtig aber
dafür hat es eben auch andere vorzüge
aber trump ist jemand gewesen
oder ist jemand der vor allem diese
schwäche ausnutzen indem er die
gesellschaft noch weiter versucht zu
spalten weil es gab jedoch auch
präsidenten vor ihm die versucht haben
dann auch das andere lager zu umarmen zu
sagen ja ich weiß ihr habt mich nicht
gewählt ich möchte trotzdem präsident
von allen amerikanern seien ja der
französische wieder amerikanische
präsident haben ja etwas was wir auch so
nicht kennen die sind ja regierungschef
und staatspräsident in einer person und
diese rolle das nach innen hin
integrieren denn auch repräsentativen
staatschefs die hat dollar trocken nie
angenommen sondern er ist ja der
polarisierer vom dienst und auch der
auseinander treiber von von menschen und
das ist ein politisches geschäft
dadurch kann er opfer und opfergruppen
kreieren sich selbst auch zum opfer
machen wir im übrigen die es in den
letzten 24 stunden getan hat er ist ja
beständig dabei sich selber als opfer zu
gerieren nun ist er das opfer dunkler
mächte die die des nachts angeblich
irgendwelche berge von unbekannten
wählerstimmen in die wahllokale hinein
zaubern
das ist ja das ist ja sein motto damit
ist er groß geworden und das scheinen
die leute und das ist ja das
beunruhigende an der vergangenen nacht
zur einen hälfte des landes gut zu
finden
wenn wir es noch mal quasi um das
gespräch abzurunden einen ausblick wagen
was ist denn ihre prognose für die den
ausgang dieser wahl jetzt also das
orakel von delphi bin ich nicht man hat
man hat sich dazu leicht zu auf die
finger
natürlich sieht es im moment so aus als
sei die beiden auf dem weg zu 270 aber
gestern abend saß eben ganz anders aus
und das gilt eben davon aus dass wir die
wählerstimmen schon kennen die jetzt
noch aus zu zählen ist die wahrheit ist
wir kennen sie nicht und deswegen können
wir dieses ergebnis nicht kennen aber
dieser kleine unterschied der am ende
dazu führen wird dass der eine oder der
andere amerikanische präsident werden
wird wird führt das land selber und
mittelbar auch für uns hier in europa
gewaltige auswirkungen haben
eine eine schärfere unterscheidung in
einer demokratischen wahl zwischen zwei
so unterschiedlichen gesellschafts und
welt entwürfe kann man sich eigentlich
kaum vorstellen und deswegen ist das was
in den nächsten stunden passieren wird
von von bedeutung für die ganze welt
ein kleiner park auf vielen dank das war
ein sehr schönes schlusswort an ende
dieses langen intensiven gespräch ist
entschuldigen sie und entschuldigt bitte
das für technische schwierigkeiten
hatten wir sind aber auch gelobt worden
hier muss ich auch weiter geben an ein
kleine brockhoff dass wir damit souverän
umgegangen sind das ist einfach jetzt
auch eine neue art miteinander
interviews zu führen die vier muss ich
sagen sehr begrüßen weil sie sehr
unkompliziert ist aber manchmal hat er
auch zu kleinen schwierigkeiten führt
vielen dank dass sie mitgemacht haben
und ein stück guten abend noch wir sind
gespannt wie es weiter geht
ich danke mich bedanke mich bei ihnen
entschuldigen noch einmal die
technischen störungen
das passiert so und dann denke ich an
euch bedanke ich mich bei euch für eure
fragen und kommentare es waren viele es
sind auch wieder dran geblieben wir
werden leider jetzt nicht mehr die
pressekonferenz von joe biden mitnehmen
können weil die wohl verschoben wurde um
eine mindestens eine halbe stunde auf
unserer zeit 22 uhr danach wird sich
irgendwann noch donald trump äußern das
heißt es kann noch dauern
wer sich informiert für informieren
möchte kann das natürlich sehr gerne tun
weiterhin im zdf nach ist das heute
journal und dann noch das schon hart
update außerdem kann ich nur empfehlen
euch die zdf heute herunter zu laden mit
den entsprechenden push nachrichten das
wetter immer gut informiert und ihr
kriegt auch eine meldung wenn wir hier
wieder live gehen fast in den nächsten
tagen natürlich wieder machen werden
aber für heute machen
den deckel einfach mal erst mal drauf
ist